Speaker 1: Let's go to south. Kat from
Virginia South. Kat, you're on the air.
Speaker 7: Hello, David.
Thanks for taking my call. I actually have
on to listen, but. Yeah, I will ask you,
I'll bring something up that's been on my mind.
Speaker 1: And by the way,
are you are you originally from Virginia?
Speaker 7: No, I'm actually from Australia.
Speaker 1: Oh, OK, that makes sense.
Speaker 7: So our.
Yeah, something came up in my mind recently was
how much it actually costs to have a child in
the US. Mm-Hmm. Your. Insured or
not insured anything like that.
And if you're not insured and this is a
basic right to have a child, you know,
and you think there's very few opportunities
to have a child for free, this is reproduction.
I'm not sure if you know anything more about that.
But then you've also got the issue of the abortion
issue that's going on. And I find I've just
really found it quite shocking that it can
cost it. I mean, if you've got a private room,
you've got the money. So it all comes down to
money. Is that anything you've thought about?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, it's it's this way
with a lot of different things and depending
on, you know, what you consider a right,
you would focus in on different aspects. When I
had my random appendectomy, I believe the sticker
price was $40000. I was at the hospital in total.
I think about eight hours, I think, and it was,
you know, about 40 grand from what I've read. The
sticker price on on most deliveries can approach
$100000. And if there's complications, you know,
you could be talking about half a million every
day in the in the nick. You is just outrageous.
Yeah, I mean, this is a bigger problem. It's a
systemic problem that relates to the health
care system, but you're 100 percent correct.
Speaker 7: Yeah, I just think I mean,
I understand that there's huge problems
with the health care system, but having a baby,
you know, is it just struck me as crazy. Yeah.
It costs. I mean, at least, maybe they could.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, it's crazy, but there's
a lot of other equally crazy things in the United
States. So I don't disagree with you. It's just,
you know, I'm sort of used to it, I guess.
Speaker 7: Yeah, I guess so, yeah. Anyway,
thanks for taking my call. All right,
Speaker 1: South Cat from Virginia,
originally from Australia. Folks, I think we did
it despite the two dropped calls, one of the best
series of calls ever on the show. We will take a
break and be back with much, much more after this.